es ist für jemanden wie mich ein
eigenartiges gefühl tagebuch zu
schreiben
nicht nur dass ich noch nie geschrieben
habe sondern ich denke auch dass ich
später keiner weder ich noch irgendein
anderer für die herzens adresse eines
dreizehnjährigen schulmädchens
interessieren wird wenn man die
entstehungsgeschichte des films
betrachtet die lust und motivation der
produzenten auf diesen stoff er dann ist
es eine eher unangenehme überraschung
was der film alles nicht schafft ergibt
sich so gut wie keine mühe den blick des
mädchens alle in eine eigenständige
bildsprache zu übersetzen
diese szene am meer könnte im film ein
starkes visuelles motiv sein als
inbegriff der freiheit von der anne
träumt aber dazu müsste sich hans
steinbichlers regie vom erzählt prinzip
der nachahmen bebilderung lösen
tut sie aber nicht die regie folgt dem
prinzip unerbittlich
jetzt eigentlich was du da redest
wie würdest du das alles verbietet nur
weil die zufällig im gebiss straßenbahn
kam schlimm
anstatt die formen des tagebuchs
filmisch ernst zu nehmen alle anderen
personen als gestalten eines
vorstellungskraft zu zeigen hat der
regisseur einen ensemble und
ausstattungs film gedreht
niemand der die zahllosen
dokumentationen zum thema kennt braucht
noch diesen film
dafür hat regisseur steinbichler aber
den großen apparat des historischen
kinos in gang gesetzt
die ausstatter haben das dreistöckige
hinterhaus mit dem begehbaren
aktenschrank penibel nachgebaut
die tricktechnik zaubern einen
britischen bomber auf die leinwand
ja und auch die schauspieler von ulrich
noethen bis martina gedeck modellieren
ihre puppenhaften figuren mit
vorbildlichem jeder ton jede geste sitzt
den nachbarn dürfen nicht wissen dass
jemand lebt
handwerkliches können und geistige
unselbstständigkeit verbinden sich zu
jener schulfunk ästhetik die aus filmen
wie diesem spricht mag sein dass am
anfang des projekts die liebe stand
zuletzt aber siegte die angst und die
pedanterie